Peter Brad and Seana thin McGuinness you
have joined us is the first time we've
had a foursome right here on the lobby
how does it feel you always remember
your first for some you thank you we're
gonna play at crawl which is a video
game you guys you guys it's a video game
of gabe newell inish look yeah pick him
as your as your God look son there there
MZ hey are you even this is a game that
just passed green light it is a four
player winner stays on dungeon crawler
game did we played a bit asa kindness is
the term the kids are thrown towards el
what it is asynchronous no AC
symmetrical that's the one it's no it's
very synchronous who's the human so sick
that might be me Peter's the human I'm
the brown ghost I am the other Brown
goes I think the brain goes is coming
right now actually is Oh joke you're
always talking about your Brown ghost
danny and i am the blue go so basically
the three of us have to try and kill the
human and i can't leave the room until I
kill all the monster exactly I'm the
last person who gets to like a final
hitch and then becomes the human Allah
predator tag from alien vs predator pain
or not I'm coming for you dude with a
sword oh come on I'm just a spider what
do you have a backswing some bull that's
some bull ass so that goes we can like
inhabit those little law and pentagrams
on the floor you would have it one of
those you become a critter they're also
going to be traps that we can inhabit
like it will shoot flames and stuff if
are also fun oh I can hit any of those
yet have died there's more pentagrams
keep doing it this guy's got ranged
about two and then the other thing about
it is that yeah I ma we got a Pelton
from afar oh you don't let him do this I
knew his eerie openness is distance
final hit someone got the final hints oh
yeah oh I thought I had you get dad yeah
yes oh I'm a dude no are you gonna it
forget our alliance et oh yeah we were
friends not but 30 seconds ago Fred I
gotta leave all my ghost friends behind
man
come on moving on up there's no game is
about getting your friends for getting
your ghost friends leaving the ghost in
their past there any point to whacking
boxes at you so here's we got some
objects in this room you you're wherever
is in control i read a book I'm gonna
fire balls of fire you want to being in
here that's actually meeting so is it
are the enemies I game always player
control do you run into NPC enemies I
haven't yet I think there's a boss at
the end which is why but even those
people control the boss oh really it's
yeah a guy so for a kit for killing the
last hero you get a bunch of gold for it
as well and then the other thing is this
kind of like finding out Binding of
Isaac star whereas at the end there's a
finish to this level oh I have to pick
up the gold and then you get to level up
your monsters so the next time you land
in the pentagram your mom or even better
because also the human level 20 I'm
leaving a tiny little monkey less no but
what are you in the game hahaha sick
burn sick turn at Mary Kish played this
over the weekend she completed it and
said it took about an hour and what it's
also wipes oh no this is this is already
accessed on this is yeah really early
access still very like they're gonna be
a lot more those trying to think my
mother's early yeah yeah premature
premature as we go nope come on let's do
bad all you think you can chase me on a
I'm a nimble little homunculus kills me
what number four oh yeah this game pasta
yeah and like I just recently except
those dudes very cool Center said this
already code so are you always
guaranteed to make it to the end of the
game because once you die you just swap
in a new player or is there like a
shared pool of lives or something like I
think maybe you can get it in the first
okay yeah so it's always guaranteed it's
just musical chairs replace the human
along the way dr. Milot death go that's
high concept it's the new dota yeah it's
the new toner go into an area where i
can spawn and murder you it was just
like a ton of track oh that don't go
area you're going to some real tight
areas daddy's yeah yeah what do you
bring those boxes bro you know that
Brown bore this guy again your mom
eating really badly uh yeah i'm leaving
like long trails of blood around the
higher plate why won't you just let the
brown ghost go free you can do something
with a little like like you can summon
those blobs yeah you can make like
duplicate verses of them it's kind of
it's uh yeah this does a lot of us go
going to go as games and go this way now
we're the last waters that's what I was
trying to do yeah and there's some sick
doors here Oh what Baba it should have
hit that thing and I realize now red has
drawn gangs boss video games com asks
where close game be purchased oh its
vices it's currently making its way to
steam so it's past green light which
means edge dance dodge roll third is
working Howard net indeed I'm gonna try
some magic out Mary said magic dodging
is better than magic but I'm really
gonna try I'm kitty we're in the store
relax hey man why I am ready Chris I'm a
retainer you don't ignore any options
menu there's like grass and things that
only one of you has summoned a winner
yeah bit do you need to be directly on
that do you want to spend eight minutes
adjusting your y-axis oh yeah i mean the
stores right back there in case of
morning really i'm the blue buff think
the other thing as well as that the air
always the tiny man the creature you
spawn us is completely is random too so
you can live a lot like we're enough
real bad girl they're getting owned by
me sitting in the spider web no yeah so
Boing about being a tiny man is that you
really blend into the scenery you know
we can see the time I helped all of my
blood I am human oh no now he's got new
human like oh hey I'm get this tiny go
Mandy come on no no can we get this XP
NFL surrounding the XP in your condo XP
for a wider juice ah I'm just a simple
tiny known man yeah yeah yeah
oh look at this look at all these
trapping online here those are cool
where's the store Oh going on it I'm
gonna hide in the store like Chris
waters day oh come on wait wait i'm just
a jumping modern age yeah hey Jim do
friends we go Bam Bam Bam oh we got bear
chomp oh you stepped in my trap and now
i'm gonna human you got my little red
guy if you have any more questions about
crawl or have the latest score in the
arsenal of Bayern Munich game please
feel free to send us tweets or send them
in the chat on gamespot or twitch you
are getting all right getting what so
you go to store you can go to the store
and buy something maybe ha ha ha I
thought that was a sword in the stone
situation you barely smoked Oh nuts wow
you're gonna tacking these crystal
shards this is pretty good you're
getting Spanish is a bad situation to be
in Tigers I go here that's here what's
this what's that oh let's go this way
ooh accord they're still bleeding oh
you're gonna die in here you were going
to die in Iran doing oh yeah I know
exactly I know this game tiny little no
men ah [ __ ] yeah I'm lon ghost yeah I'll
go yama ghost King Yama goes almost
there all right next next death and
we're done here fo oh no I'm sorry guys
been pent up as a brown girl could be
long you know why I last name is right
Peter Brown goes sometimes when I have a
burrito and I wake up the next morning I
really have this get rid of the brown
goes Oh real spiritual with your
digestive process Wow totes goes can buy
us brands of stuff at the store that
you're not cuz trans down cuz of time
reading
all right here's the love them last room
exciting if this is near the last one
tiny man am I gonna be a tiny man nope
I'm bad three bats all right we need to
keep our distance all right distance
gentleman with his mom going from
welcome from afar you know his weakness
besides tendencies blue balls weaknesses
blue balls blue balls at him Tori my
government like my throbbing blue bowl
assailed him with your blue balls there
we go oh and that's a wrap that is crawl
Oh steam everly Howard's four all.com
Peter Brian McGinnis the rumors going on